In 2017, Netflix was knee-deep in superhero
projects.
In addition to “MCU-sorta” properties
like Daredevil and Jessica Jones, they announced
a new set of comic series originating from
the Millarworld brand of comics — from world-famous
writer Mark Millar.
While general audiences have seen some of
Millar's work receive live-action adaptations
before in the form of "Kingsman" and "Kick-Ass,"
these streaming series would explore a world
still unfamiliar to most.
A new universe of possibilities kicked off
on May 7th, 2021, when the first of these
adaptations — "Jupiter's Legacy" — debuted
on Netflix.
The new show exhibited precisely how it would
differentiate itself in a crowded market of
superhero properties with equal parts familial
drama and fight scenes.
And that's not even mentioning the series'
dazzling cast, featuring the likes of Josh
Duhamel as the Utopian, Ben Daniels as Brainwave,
Leslie Bibb as Lady Liberty, Matt Lanter as
Skyfox, and more.
Unfortunately, unlike the heroes at the center
of the show who can live well over a century,
"Jupiter's Legacy" has suffered an untimely
death.
While the word "cancelation" may not have
come up explicitly, it's pretty clear that
Netflix plans on teleporting "Jupiter's Legacy"
Season 2 out of existence.
On June 2nd, 2021, not even a month after
Season 1 debuted, Mark Millar himself broke
the news that season 2 wasn’t happening,
taking to Twitter to share an image of a statement
addressing the situation, plus some extra
commentary in the caption and in a follow-up
tweet.
Millar said,
"I'm really proud of what the team achieved
with Jupiter's Legacy and the amazing work
everyone did on that origin season.
I've been asked a lot about what we're planning
next with this world, and the answer is to
see what the super-villains are getting up
to.
We've made the tough call of letting our incredible
cast out of their show commitment."
He noted in his statement that he's "confident
that [they'll] return to it later" — though
it's unclear who the “they” is.
Netflix?
Millar and his team?
Another streaming service?
Netflix tends to stay tight-lipped on its
shows' viewing numbers unless they're phenomenal.
As such, the assumption is that "Jupiter's
Legacy" didn't do too well in that regard,
especially since the cast was let out of their
contracts entirely.
The predominantly negative critical reviews
for "Jupiter's Legacy" could have played a
part in the demise of Season 2.
Jupiter's Legacy" has a mere 38% critical
approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes, though
its audience score is more than double that,
sitting at 72%.
There is no doubt that the show has a rabid
fan base, and Millar himself has a strong
following, so all this is a bit of a surprise
to have the axe fall so quickly.
For the time being, the show's quick demise
is a sizable financial loss for Netflix.
Borys Kit of the Hollywood Reporter mentioned
on Twitter that sources have suggested Jupiter's
Legacy Season 1 cost a reported $200 million
to make.
Expensive plus bad reviews plus perhaps not
that large of an audience equals no season
two.
Clearly, the financial aspect is critical
to all this, but on the bright side, in not
making another season of a show that might
have gotten the axe thereafter, Netflix isn't
pouring more money down the drain.
Instead, money is being poured into a different
place.
Some of the other Millarworld projects currently
in development at Netflix include "The Magic
Order," "American Jesus," and "Sharkey the
Bounty Hunter".
Hopefully, those don’t end up being a drain
on Netflix and their adventures into more
comic-based streaming shows.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about comic-based
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.